- You're a crazy genius.
And I like working with crazy geniuses.
- You have boundaries.
I don't. Not anymore.
- Our big idea
was to take a little bit of this...
- (laughs)
- ...a little bit of that.
You mix these things together...
- (screams)
-...and what you get is--
- Now you're in my world. (echoes)
- How in the hell
do you plan on pulling that off?
- Oh, you watch.
- Snap to it.
- This is my life.
- Aah!
- This is what I am.
- That's the thing no one can buy.
- In life, you need to keep fighting.
- ♪ You gotta fight ♪
- Whoa, girl, look at you.
- ♪ To party ♪
- This is my legacy.
- Our legacy.
- Our legacy. Whatever.
(sonar beeping)
- Here they come.
- Immortality won't come from
you following the rules.
It's going to come from you
breaking them.